did you know that China spends more on
chips than it does on oil no not those
chips like microchips silicon Wafers
that are at the center of All
Electronics and that make our world go
round these chips by the way are at the
center of rising tensions between the
United States and China this is economic
War the Biden Administration right now
is making it so that American chip
makers can't sell chips to China for
going billions of dollars of Revenue
usually American Presidents don't want
American companies to lose out on a
bunch of money so what's going on here
well it turns out that a lot of Chinese
companies are buying American microchips
and then secretly using them for like
military things there's really a blurry
line between businesses and the military
in China kind of in the United States
too TBH but anyway all of this has
created a situation where chips are like
the new oil whoever controls the
microchips has the geopolitical power
this is a big deep story I just made a
30 minute video on it that explains
everything with lots of beautiful maps
that are like neon colored and a lot of
really good reporting so go check that
out